vitres éclatées pare-brise défoncé c'est
la fin d'une traque de plusieurs heures
l'assaillant de levallois-perret
désormais hors d'état de nuire
retour sur cette journée où la france a
été la cible d'une nouvelle attaque
il est environ 8 heures ce matin
levallois perret en région parisienne un
groupe de militaires s'engagent sur la
place de verdun
il s'apprête à partir en mission
lorsqu'un véhicule noir les percute de
plein fouet
six d'entre eux sont blessées dont trois
gravement
les militaires faisaient tous partie du
35ème régiment d'infanterie de belfort
il était présent sur les lieux dans le
cadre de l'opération sentinelle qui vise
à renforcer la sécurité sur le
territoire national vers 13 heures le
ministre de l'intérieur et la ministre
des armées se rende au chevet des
blessés
les images diffusées sur le compte
twitter de gérard collomb sont
rassurantes quant à l'état de santé des
militaires
à ce moment là le suspect est toujours
en cavale
à la suite de cette nouvelle attaque le
ministre de l'intérieur se veut vigilant
ça veut dire que la menace reste
aujourd'hui extrêmement importante et
que nos forces de sécurité nos forces
militaires sont toujours prises pour
cibles il est bientôt 14 heures lorsque
l'assaillant est enfin arrêté son
véhicule est immobilisé sur l'autoroute
a16 à marquise dont le pas de calais
trois cents policiers ont participé à
cette traque
à 15 heures les députés se lève
symboliquement pour faire part de la
reconnaissance de la nation à ses forces
armées
dix mille militaires sont toujours en
place sur le territoire dans le cadre de
l' opération sentinel
[Applaudissements]